hello everyone my name is Jim Leyland
I'm with the original identity and today
we are talking about a topic that
actually is very pregnant to the
conference here it's beyond genomics
preparing for the avalanche avalanche of
person I'm a clinical findings I think a
lot of the talks here talk about genome
sequencing and starting to do it for
patients the question really is you know
what's the next step to be able to help
these patients a lot of these patients
would have no they find in gene or they
have a listening the question is how can
we sort of continue to help them so
that's a question that we are a genomics
are trying to do and hopefully will dig
a little bit into this problem and then
some of the solution that will
programming and that together I think at
the community we can start thinking
about arm descriptive problem and we
know that is you know where small group
it's not going to be us with no sobbing
it's a whole communities and I do it
together so a little bit our background
we are a nonprofit that is mostly in the
US but also we have sites in Singapore
Malaysia Australia Israel now in China
South Korea that are coming and what we
do is we connect where do these patients
with clinical sequencing sites and help
them with the logistics finding the
right clinician finding the right mental
geneticist sequencing capacity helping
interpret the information if they need
it and then also sort of helping them
with fundraising if their insurance is
that is not able to sort of cover that
as many of you know is that there are a
million two million the patient that
have rare diseases are undiagnosed and
many people in the conference know about
the whole bag methodology was read to
these patients and this is a very large
problem and be able to solve it business
this require not only sort of top-down
efforts with as well as bottom up
efforts which we're trying to do from
empowering and enabling patients
themselves partnering with an academic
institution to come
marshall ventures to be able to work
together and this number that people
throw out between 7,000 8,000 great
diseases in each of them you know
there's probably going to be more as
more genome sequencing is done and all
these large initiatives like an abelian
thinners or initial initiatives in the
UK and this as a long-tailed problem is
a little bit different than what science
is used to in terms of a top-down system
is actually trend sort of build from the
bottom up and and we know that rare
disease ultimately even if you diagnose
therapies are going to be what's most
important and currently less than you
know about three percent of rare
diseases have any type of therapy and no
cures so as people who work in genomics
our goal really is to be able to help
the patients so diagnosis really of the
first step of this process so this is
what we are we're genomics is trying to
do so I'm going to get to talk about
quickly what we do in a genomics I and
then we'll be able to sort of dive
deeper into sort of the post-genomic
side and this part you know would be a
little bit quick so what we do is
provide three separate aspects of this
of technology scientists and funding to
this and a lot of conference you will be
the scientists and technology that would
be needed for this and some of the stuff
that we've done would sort of tailor and
would actually fit with a lot of what
people are doing in this conference soul
in one of our first cases is about sort
of three years ago now which seems like
you have the go in genomics is one of
our first patients are Robert he's one
of your classic diagnostic Odyssey
patients he was born healthy and about
an age one he sort of had a neurological
decline unable to use his muscled unable
to be rushed to hospital and started
their whole diagnostic Odyssey process
by the time that they came to us of you
know dozens of years later around 14
years later I believe this is at the
beginning of the whole genomic era of
nobody had really even figured out what
kind of diseases to hear whether it was
about a country of disease where there's
economic disease so we set off I'm
starting to do that and this is before
all sort of the next-gen sequencing is
now sort of
for genetic diseases so the thing that
we did in the past that we continue to
do is connect them with a PEC technology
of which right now mostly what we do is
sort of NGS type of sequencing with
external capture and that's pretty
standard and if there are those
confidence you probably sort of know a
lot about this the second thing that we
do is then we connect them to other
commercial sites or research studies
that would be able to help these are
some of the study centers that we
participated in the past that have
either created whether they have already
commercial pipeline to do that whether
they have a research pipeline it all
depends on whether they fit into certain
research materials whether they have
kept clear it from services that's ready
for that we can connect them to and now
we're starting working a lot with sort
of overseas which don't have the luxury
of all these sort of clinical and NGO
services and like a magellan India
Singapore Malaysia Australia and working
with partners all over the world in the
u.s. is no other the clinical services
are much more available now the hard
part is still actually insurance
reimbursement so that's where it's
really the third step comes in I mean
the beginning when we were doing this
there was basically no reimbursement
whatsoever for this and so we created a
platform where patients can raise funds
to their friends and family and and now
although there's some of our patients
are getting reimbursement but they're
still it's still a hard road for many
patients and so we will help them going
to connect them with later using our
pipeline so we not only now have a pump
long we have coaching to help them we
have template letters that can be sent
out so our goal is with these patients
if they don't have the right technology
we connect them to the right centers if
they have the right centers we can then
help them with fundraising I'm really
you know as an a proper we we help the
patients from beginning to end so this
is sort of from our own screen capture
site some of our patients that we will
create a page for them for the verb and
most people know on this conference is
in other casa valve you know left in ten
thousand dollars and it be raised and we
sort of help patients be able to braces
it can happen at really depending on
this
network of the individual we've done
campaigns as quick as one day which is
as you crazy desert see them when you
come in were the average is in a few
months for people to be able to raise
funds I want to funds are raised and we
release all the funds then to the
finding minus in the processing fees
from the engine from front of the credit
card companies ended but we don't sort
of take any money from that it goes
directly to patient to be able to help
that home and with sort of up and down a
reimbursement environment I think this
is going to be an important aspect that
we will continue to play so we like to
think about it this picture this
obviously is not the actual team but we
think about the robber going from being
being someone out of diagnostic Odyssey
to now not only scientists be able to
help them but I know funders and
researchers all over the world to be
able to help and and like many other
diagnostic Odyssey stories you know we
were able actually to find a gene from
him and his his gene is pyaar tera hey
and it's a type of dystonia called
dystonia at 16 he is one of left and
then approximately a dozen patients in
the world that has this and and we're
excited and but then the question is
what next you know you found a gene but
but how can we really be able to
leverage that to be able to help the
families so we partnered and in
discussions and you know these are sort
of evolving with with you know and with
other groups and these are many other
groups that do this right now I know now
there's a large you know really what it
would Forge or sentiment doing genomics
there's a big avalanche of data that's
coming out but then the question is
what's next going to be helped them
after you find a gene what really is a
poor papa g so we really still releasing
diagnosis is that first step and the
real work is is that sort of the bottom
of the iceberg if you will and this is
really the avalanche of data so in the
beginning when you have those initial
stories of ending diagnostic Odyssey is
you know like the cooker or or for
example with the berry twins right you
have a lot of scientists willing able to
but as we have more and more of this
data coming out it is it is no longer
you know just simple to be able to find
scientists will be able to take these
studies and start doing functional
studies to be able to understand these
genes many of these genes are
unannotated so then the question is how
do we do that the number that within the
field that people report is enough
proximately a quarter to a third of
these diagnostic Odysseys and is some
sort of result but then the question is
what do you do with it with the test and
for us what we really think that this is
sort of not not sort of like a rosetta
stone written in stone kind of process
this really needs to be a living
document if you will because a lot of
annotation databases get better as more
more genomes or sequence actually
initial quote unquote findings that
there are high suspects of jeans for
these patients often will turn out not
to be so how do we go from to looking at
as a sort of static process to something
that that is much more sort of dynamic
and fluid so the way to do so what we
think about really is more of the
process where you know there's constant
editing and this really needs to be more
than a report that is a static piece of
paper that integrated into the patient
record but ways that we can continue to
go back and relook at and annotate data
and this is going to be very hard right
this is not an easy task to continue to
go back and look at the data we analyzed
it and has more more patient or have
this data than and how are we able to be
able to help and as we know that right
even even in every step of the process
whether it's generating basis or
sequence alignment or variant calling
there's better knowledge spaces there
better calling I'm algorithms you know
calling that just based on one sample
open are multiple samples better
alignment algorithms and and it's you
know it'll keep on getting better so
then how can these patients be able to
really benefit from that so we see this
process really as a we really are in the
larval stage and with helping these
patients in a very very beginning of
this and how can we build an ecosystem
that we can really think about
it has it close to the next step so what
we what we are proposing is surely build
an ecosystem for that it's just a
picture and it it's going to require
many many different components of that
and we're at the beginning of doing that
and fluffy a little bit overview of what
we're trying to build in there in terms
of each of these components are GI so
these components really come from three
aspects first storage and sharing you
need a place to store all this data that
page you can access number two is
scientific validation to really find it
is you know is that gene candidate
really the gene and then lastly it's
connecting connecting patients to each
other connecting to scientists to really
understand that more so let's first talk
about storage and sharing and this is
going to be a little bit different and
every context is going to be very
specific in terms of return of data how
much should be returned is that a piece
of paper is a one gene and this you know
continually evolve in this discussion
here but we're hoping and what we're
trying to do is if we can give the
patient than most data that they can
have access to with sort of guidance
expertise they potentially be able to
sort of make more of this much more use
of this data and then have this at such
a role living document so here we have
system to be able to store three types
of data the standard medical record data
on where it's often very important in
working turns to be able to understand
the genome the research data so again
this is sort of you know people you know
you could be as radical as the PGP to
return everything you couldn't turn the
feet you know VCF files and how patients
are going to work with that it's no
constant and sort of debated but but
what we're hoping to do is and we're
partnering with so that we can be able
to return research data actually VCF
files or vampires you can factor the
patient and then lastly I'll be able to
soar actually bounced specimen and
biobank in case they want to do any type
of follow-up work that already it's a
biobank that it's their own specimen and
that if you want to do additional
analysis like you know transcriptomics
proteomics that you have that ready so
we already have some partner
we're in discussion words were further
discussion patient know best is what we
use for right now storing and all our
our electronic medical records that sort
of HIPAA compliant we're working with
and continually working with the open
medicine institute be able to store VCF
data some of our pcs data also we can
store with patient know best which
actually is now working with to genomics
so then they can put you know additional
and of our annotation on that as well so
we see this as a trend it's not going to
be easy transition and people are not
used to sort of what did what are the
mean we give all the data back but i
think there's ways that we can start to
sort of have this conversation and
lastly a working wood feels like the
genetic alliance to be able to store
biobanking in a patient specifically you
don't just donate it to the University
to advocacy group but they themselves
get to have ownership of that data it's
controlled by the patient so with this
you know you really can then store your
records and beta your specimen which
then you can start thinking about how
you can act upon it and to be able to
make the most of this information
whether you have a gene of interest list
of genes of interest or you're one of
the two thirds that you don't know what
to do next and with addition and a
patient you hope to be able to find
things for them so the second sort of
leg of this process is is sort of
scientific validation and and what we do
is is there's again three aspects that
we do firstly it sort of crowdsourcing
ideas and I will sort of talk a little
bit more about that is how can we show
leverage all the different sides of the
expertise in the world potentially to be
able to weigh in on this because we're
diseases span the gamut or biological
study there's no there's not an ever
large enough group of experts are able
to help them secondly its computation on
reanalysis to run different pipelines to
be able to do that I'm aware in
discussion with different foods be able
to do that and elastic experimental
validation so I'm going to talk about
the first thing crowdsourcing of ideas
we're doing that right now we're just
sort of piloting in a house and just
sort of simple bulletin board system
what we with the patient's permission be
able to post anonymize sort of
information about the case and and
scientists will then be able to sort of
wing in our potential strategies whether
an additional profile and molecular bio
media whether their expert in this gene
other experts we also connect them to
people working on those jeans you know
through for men and others and really to
be able to find the best experts to be
able to help these patients the second
thing if we sort of go back to sort of
the three stages computational analysis
and and these are some of others of
weeks or in discussion we will work with
in the past is web different pipelines
that we can rerun and these are just
your representative but as as better
algorithms come out but annotations
literally it's coming out I think being
able to really analyze and really be
able to give patients the ability to do
that and of course there's a lot of
caveats you know with what's happening
with 23andme what's happening with what
does it mean to be sort of
direct-to-consumer both but would with
sort of the proud work protocol rrb
oversight there are ways that we think
that the patient can be really empowered
engaged in this process and for that
reanalysis of her not necessarily have
all the burden on the companies who sort
of do it initially but but this is
something that we're piling ourselves to
sort of think about to build it and we
think that now this potentially this
really is needed that's the data we're
getting it right now it's still so
sparse with better databases this
reanalysis we think is going to be very
very important the last part of this
sort of scientific validation process
effect here is experimental validation
so experimental validation it's
obviously very very difficult for the
patient to do when we're not suggesting
sort of a DIY bio movement but more we
partner with CR OS and potentially do
this so our main partner is as a Depot
which is our CRO marketplace at math
databases of thousands of different CRO
companies so then if the cloud source of
scientific ideas can propose a certain
study maybe that they can depreciate
themselves can in
same way that they fund some of the
genomic studies find additional studies
or creation of reagents to be able to
help understand and take it to the next
stage and we we've done this not only on
an individual basis but also with a
large competition so in the past these
are some of the companies that we
partner with to give away either
software or reagents or even so the
model organism to be able to understand
into individual cases and and there are
many many instances now in the
literature whether it's the my family at
the wealthy family whether the boe
family ahem holds a lot of families that
are pushing forward research on their
own but it really it's a large heroic
effort and takes really special
infrastructure and family members to be
able to do that and what we want to do
is make that much much easier and create
this partnership and and ultimately our
goal really is you know we don't think
that were these simple systems and
ecosystem that will create will be able
to solve it and at the end it's
connecting to the right groups and
researchers to really take that to the
next page our goal is if we can generate
enough data bio banking research even
you know some organisms or IPS stem cell
line that will make it easier for
researchers to be able to take this and
be able to develop you know pipe organs
and develop research program from that
or to pull it together to do it in the
more in-depth analysis so in terms of
connecting we have three different
strategies that were working on one is
through a patient registry to get all
these patients and register not only in
terms of what disease they have but
what's that genomic background secondly
is sort of an online community for
patients that communicate with each
other with the same genetic changes so
you know your favorite gene you can
collect all the people with the same
genetic mutations and maybe they can
talk to each other and lastly is patient
centric sharing to be able to sort of
share that data so the way do it the
registry we're working currently working
with Sanford help to build a genomic
registry registry now just based on
diseases but on the
there gym bag background I work actively
with in discussion with them on this the
second thing is we recently Tricia
decided to join us and it's an online
community of 7,000 plus of the diseases
and we are middle of rolling out
communities based on genes to allow
patients to be able to connect with each
other in this sort of social media way
and lastly word word develop what we're
calling over to these comments where
patients are able to potentially you
know make open source or share their
data in a very similar way that the PGP
does it look a lot to them for where do
these patients often privacy is of
secondary concern and they want to make
it all public and and if they are the
ones who make it public nobody can stop
them right with but of course we can
need to guide them to make them
understand and in similar way that the
PGP has very extensive training and
testing to make sure people understand
what they're getting into to be able to
do that so in short we are sort of
trying to build this ecosystem to be
dinner and this is you know hopefully
one effort of many great this and
they're a large no large much larger
efforts at the NIH and our academic
institutions are building this but we
hope to be one of the many voices to do
that and take all these different
athletes that we discuss and to be able
to really help so for Robert actually
we've been able to connect him with some
researchers at the NIH and Canada and
who are actively studying his his cell
line and doing functional studies for
his jeans and were excited that he not
only gets a gene diagnosis but hopefully
one day would have substantive
therapeutic options and to be able to
help and ultimately Robert will be one
of many many patients are the millions
of patients are you know more and more
studies not just sort of identifying the
gene but how do we really ultimately I
don't change sort of their fall of your
life and be able to help them
so thank you very much that's a little
bit over a quick overview where we're
working on on our GI and you have any
question happy to dialogue and of course
as we see this as a large effort for the
whole community we have a large number
of scientists who work with us and we
would love to sort of be in conversation
so here's my you know my emails here and
feel free to connect with us and
hopefully we can together be able to
help more patients together thank you
very much the question well I don't see
any questions so if you have any further
questions later feel free to email me
and my work with us and that looks at
about thank you very much